u.s president joe biden and his russian
counterpart vladimir putin will meet for
talks
in geneva as relations between the two
countries hit a low point
now biden arrived in the swiss city
saying he was ready for a tough
encounter with the russian president
he has promised to set clear red lines
between washington
and moscow but says he hopes there will
be areas for cooperation
the summit will be putin and biden's
first face-to-face meeting as
leaders and is expected to last for
several hours
let's get the latest on the story we
have dw's alexander phenomenon covering
the summit for us in geneva and yuri
rochetto is standing by
in moscow welcome to you both alexander
let's
start with you there in geneva so talk
us through the big points
on the agenda today
there is a full range of pressing issues
on the agenda according
to the white house you asked president
joe biden once
to talk about moscow's aggressive
actions in ukraine
he wants to call out russia for human
rights abuses
the poisoning of the opposition leader
alexey navalny
but i think when the leaders come
together at the villa la grange
right behind me it's a cyber security
that will be at the top
of the agenda there have been a few
significant far-reaching cyber attacks
in the u.s
lately some of them having russian
fingerprints on them
one targeted america's biggest fuel
pipeline so the us wants russia
to do more to deter to deter such
attacks from within its voters
well you know alexander just a few
months a week ago we saw the u.s
president say when he was asked that
vladimir putin is a killer he's talked
about drawing red lines in this meeting
so
how tense do you think the summit is
going to be
well fact is that the relations between
the two countries
are at a very low point and the us
president joe biden he has made clear
that
he wants to be tough on russia however
my impression is
that he's also interested in lowering
the temperature a notch or two and
white house officials told us that the
main goal here is to find areas where
both
sides can work together on climate
change for example on solving
international crises in libya for
example or
in syria the big question of course is
whether vladimir putin will play along
yuri that brings us to you there in
moscow this uh effort perhaps to
to bring temperatures down a bit i mean
we know that president biden will
confront
president putin with these allegations
that russian hackers have been behind
these big cyber attacks so
from your perspective there in moscow
how contentious do you think this is
going to be
well some are pretty contentious i think
but some progress could be achieved as
well at this point because ahead of the
summit
both moscow and washington have already
made some steps
that might seem unusual against the
backdrop of tensions in recent years
they've tried to smooth some of the
sharper edges of the relationship
avoid unnecessary signals that could
escalate the situation and they even
exchanged already
what could be called some kind of
compliment the american president said
that he is that he perceives his russian
colleague as a worthy rival and vladimir
putin here in moscow for his part spoke
very positively
about biden's team praising them for
their professionalism in an interview
tv interview when asked about cyber
attacks against the us and
the possible extradition to the united
states of russian hackers
who have committed those cyber attacks
president putin admitted in an interview
it was a possibility once appropriate
agreements have been reached with
washington
that was a kind of signal to the white
house indicating the kremlin's goodwill
and readiness for dialogue at this point
and yuri just quickly what do you think
president putin wants to get
out of this meeting
a direct a direct dialogue between the
two men that's exactly what
the russian president said he wants to
establish russian-american relations are
probably already at their lowest point
since
the collapse of the soviet union from
here they can only get better
although both sides are warning against
high expectations
still the importance of this meeting
shouldn't be underestimated
the main thing now is to try to start
salvaging relations from their current
level and prevent a direct possibly
armed clash
between the two nuclear countries such
as scenario sumi has become more and
more realistic given the way things have
developed in recent years
first of all because russia and the
united states had stopped talking
altogether and stage
not reached even during the cold war and
both sides probably have a weak
understanding of where the so-called
so-called red lines are those lines that
shouldn't be crossed under any
circumstances
so here in moscow they're convinced that
neither of the two presidents will shake
hands for just for the record
putin wants to achieve results even if
that only means resuming
the bilateral bilateral dialogue under
today's conditions even that would be a
lot
our correspondent siri rochette there in
moscow alexander fornamen in
geneva thank you